ben oui bonsoir monsieur nicolas lui
nous venons dans le cadre des élections
municipales vous présenter notre
programme
auriez vous l'amabilité de nous ouvrir
s'il vous plaît pour vous dépose le
programme opération porte à porte dans
ses résidences du centre-ville des
clayes-sous-bois pour nicolas eu à la
tête de la liste divers gauche un autre
projet pour les clayes-sous-bois il
vient présenter plus en détail
l'ensemble de ces propositions
parmi les thèmes qui lui tiennent
particulièrement à coeur la solidarité
la convivialité et l'environnement nous
souhaitons redonner une réelle cohérence
et un vrai vivre ensemble à l'ensemble
de la commune notamment en développant
des circulations qui permettent aux
habitants de se rendre d'un
lieu à l'autre et d'un quartier à un
autre est de pouvoir justement un vivre
de manière cohérente au sein de la
commune et donc lens projet l'on vous
propose
une vingtaine de propositions pendant
cent propositions précisément autre
projet concret mis en avant par le
candidat la sauvegarde du parc du centre
desbruyères la création d'une maison de
santé ou encore la redynamisation du
commerce de proximité un programme
construit avec l'ensemble des colistiers
et un an j'étais gilet jaune sur les
ronds-points des clayes-sous-bois et
jean nicolas hué venu me rencontrer et
c'était le soleil vient me voir c'était
divers il faisait froid mais c'est le
seul élu qui s'est donné la peine de se
déplacer et venir nous rencontrer savoir
ce que nous allions dire je me suis
retrouvé dans ce que nicolas eu pour
thème comme valeur pour les absents ce
jour là nicolas eu suspend un accroche
porte pour indiquer sa venue avant le
premier tour des élections d'autres
opérations sont prévues par la liste une
randonnée cycliste citoyenne le 29
février et trois réunions publiques